Comme si tout ce qu'on
reprochait à M. O'Toole a ét
révélé au grand jour. Voici
notre reportage.
(klaxon)
- Aux abords du Parlement,assous
encaissent le coup.
- C'est une triste journée pour
notre chef, pour notre parti,
pour notre mouvement.
Calgary Shepard, Alb
- C'est une journée triste
pour notre chef, pour notre
parti, pour notre mouvement.
- Erin O'Toole, ancien militaire
de Stephen Harper, n'a pas
réussi à convaincre
les conservateurs qu'il était
l'homme de la situation.
Son règne à la tête d
demi.
- Je vais humblement
quitter mon poste.
- Le chef déchu a évité
les médias et s'est adre
ERIN O'TOOLE, chef sortant
du Parti conservateur
- C'était une fierté pour moi
de diriger le parti.
- Nombreux détracteurs
lui re c c c c c c c c c c c c t
ses positions. Après avoir fait
volte-face sur la taxe carbo
et les armes à feu, Erin O'Toole
a, une fois de plus, changé
son fusil d'épaule la semaine
"Les gens avaient du mal
à nous suivre,  q q q q q q q qe
j'ai voté pour qu'il soit démis
de ses fonctioefefefefef."
DIMITRI SOUDAS, ancien dir. des
communications de Stephen
tout le monde. Et c'est là où
M. O'Toole a manqué d'au
de dire : voici ce que je crois,
et voici où j'avais amené
le parti.
problème plus profond au sein de
la famille conse.....
LUC BERTHOLD, député du PCC,
Mégantic-L'Érable, Qc
- On ne peut y y y y y y y y y t
des divisions, qu'il y avait
des fricnsnsnsnsns le parti.
- Il y avait des divisions
qui ne devaient pas être là,
puis, é.é.é.é.é.é.é.é.é.é.é.é.é.
- Plusieurs députés de l'Ouest
n'onprprprprprécié le recentrage
qu'Erin O'Toole voulait
opérer au sein du parti,
v v v v v v v v v v v v v v v t
la course au leadership.
gegegegegegens étaient insatisfs
du message, des changements,
je dirais, de cap qui avaitàààà.
- Aujourd'hui, des élus,
notamment du Québec,
s'inquiètent de voir
la formation politique prendre
JOEL GODIN, député du PCC,
Portneuf-Jacques-Cartier, Qc
- Moi, je suis un progressiste-
conservateur et je resterai
au Parti conservateur du Canada
ce parti-là sera progressiste-
conservateur. Il faut s'unir
il faut unir les deux solitudes.
ALAIN RAYES, député du PCC,
Richmond-Arthabaska, Qc
- Une tâche qui s'annonce
difficili i i i i i i 21,
par exemple, bien des députés
des prairies veulent que le
partt t t t t t t t t t t t t tr
les chances des conservateurs
auititititititit cet ancien
ministre de Stephen Harper.
p p p p p p p p p p p p p p p r
recommencer notre parti.
- Comment regagner la confiance
des él
Les Canadiens d'éthyle ont
besoin d'un parti conser